hey everyone it's Sarah threads to nurse
our end comm and in this video I want to
demonstrate how to get up and sit down
in a chair with a walker to sit down in
a chair a patient is going to take their
Walker hold on to the hand grips and
slowly back up to the chair until they
fill the chair with the back of their
legs then they're going to slightly
extend that weak leg out and take their
hands and position them behind them and
bend their strong leg and feel for the
chairs armrests and then set down to get
up from the chair what the patient's
going to do is of course make sure the
Walker is out in front of them they're
going to lean forward out of the chair
make sure their hands are on the hand
rest and slightly extend that weak leg
out then they're going to put weight on
their hands by pushing up on the armrest
of the chair and with their strong leg
and putting their hands on the hand grip
of the Walker then they are ready to
ambulate
and again to do that they will lift the
Walker make sure all points are on the
floor move that weak leg put weight on
the handgrips and then move the strong
side thank you so much for watching and
don't forget to subscribe to our channel
for more videos